looks like we're live
all right welcome to thursday
so today we're going to get to some of
that stuff that we didn't have time for
last time if you recall at the end of
last time
uh we had an ambitious schedule where we
started to talk about consensus and then
i hoped we were going to get to
something called
flp and we didn't quite get that far so
that's what we're going to be spending
some time on today
so
we'll keep talking about uh introductory
stuff with consensus so we're going to
formally define consensus
then we're going to talk about the flp
result
and then we're going to do paxos
the consensus algorithm paxos and i
think we're going to start with
the easy parts
and then the hard parts
i'll say the interesting parts
we'll see how we do with this we may not
get through uh all of this today
but we'll see all right so
if you remember at the end of last time
we started to talk about this notion
of um consensus
as this box right that had some arrows
that went into it
and the consensus problem was
getting the thing on all of these arrows
to agree when we came out so maybe we
have a bit
going in either zero or one and we want
everybody to agree we want them to
either all say one
or we want them to all say zero either
one would be a solution to consensus
so we talked about this a little bit
last time but i'll just say it again
just so it's clear so
you might look at this and you might
think well that's not hard to do
if you want to have consensus just
there's three inputs here right so just
pick
the majority in this case one is the
majority so just go with one
or if zero had been the majority go with
zero
um and indeed this concept of majority
is going to actually be important
when we talk about consensus but the
thing that you have to remember is that
there's not some external observer like
me looking at this piece of paper
who can look at this and make this
decision of oh look this one is a
majority
instead these three processes have to do
the job of communicating among
themselves to figure out
what they think and to come up with a
situation in which they all agree
so we're going to talk about one of the
best known algorithms for doing that
which is paxos
but before we do um let's uh
let's talk a little bit about the
properties that consensus algorithms try
to
satisfy so
the first of these properties is
i'll start a new page for this the first
of these properties is termination
and i'm going to say properties that
consensus algorithms try to satisfy
for a reason
because as well as we'll see they try
but they fail so the first of these is
termination
and termination says that
each correct process
eventually decides on a value
so if termination holds then you're
eventually
going to get something
out this end of the consensus box on
every one of these lines
notice that i haven't said yet anything
about
what that something is so i haven't said
anything about them being
the same yet all i've said is that you
get something
so if you don't uh so if you get like a
zero here and a one here and
here you don't ever get anything then
that would be a violation of termination
so that's one property that you want for
sure
next is what's called agreement
and this says that all correct processes
uh decide on the same value
so agreement says that if anybody
outputs a zero then they all do
and if anyone outputs a one then they
all do
so if that was a violation of
termination
then this will be a violation of
agreement if we have like
one one zero here
okay so let me ask you a question at
this point
if these were the only two properties
that you had to satisfy
termination and agreement what could you
do then to implement consensus
if this was it that you had to satisfy
what would be a really easy way to
implement consensus then
somebody say just just fail everything
all the time not sure i understand what
that means
okay yeah so good good suggestions here
just have everyone decide a constant
just have all processes out with the
same value always
give them one all the time that's right
so if this was all you had to do
you could just say have everybody output
one
or have everybody output zero ignore the
input
there consensus done right we satisfied
termination and we satisfied agreement
well we can't do that so we need a third
property
the third one is this
it's called validity and sometimes it
goes by other names sometimes people
call it integrity
this is different from things like
database integrity constraints this is a
different use of the word integrity and
sometimes it's also called
non-triviality
so in this context all these different
words mean the same thing i like to use
the word validity
and the wording of validity varies
but the the um the version of it that
we're going to use will be this
the agreed agreed-upon value
must be
one of the proposed values
so in other words if the inputs were
uh we're all zeros
then this wouldn't be okay to have them
all output one
so this could be um this rules out the
kind of situation where we just said
just have it always output a one
so you can't do the thing where you just
ignore the input and always
output the same thing and claim to have
consensus
so in some sense
these properties put together give you a
definition
of consensus their definition of this
this thing that we want
the behavior that we want from a
consensus algorithm
so i said that consensus algorithms try
to satisfy these properties
but it turns out that in the
asynchronous network model
and recall what the asynchronous network
model is it's when there's no bound on
latency
uh between processes
it turns out that in the asynchronous
network model no consensus algorithm
actually does
satisfy all of these
does anybody know why that's true why no
consensus algorithm
satisfies all these in the in the
asynchronous network model
yeah yeah people are saying termination
sounds like it could be a problem yeah
so
no consensus algorithm satisfies all
three of these because it's impossible
and this was proved in 1983
by
three authors
michael fisher nancy lynch
and michael patterson
and it's from their names that we get
the initials flp
uh so
i guess there's one other qualification
that i forgot to add in the asynchronous
network model
and where crash faults can occur so if
you're in the crash fault model
or obviously any any fault model that
encompasses the crash fault model so the
emission fault model and so on
in the crash fault model and in the
asynchronous network model
you can't actually satisfy all three of
these properties
uh so this is a paper that you can go
and look up if you want to
uh it's called impossibility of
distributed consensus with one
faulty process and it's one of the most
classic papers in distributed systems
it's really interesting to take a look
at
i don't want to go through the details
of the proof of why this is the case
but this is a fact that you should know
that it's not possible to
actually satisfy all these things
so if you have to compromise
if you can only have two out of three at
best
which one of these things do you think
you're going to compromise on
termination yeah that's a good
suggestion yeah so
you could have a consensus algorithm but
it doesn't necessarily terminate
now there are some situations in which
you might make a different choice
interestingly but
but compromising on agreement kind of
doesn't seem great right because that's
what that's what we want right
if you're if you're okay with violating
agreement then
what's the point right because then you
know
why were we doing a consensus algorithm
anyway if we didn't care that we were
getting the same value and similarly for
validity and that seems pretty important
as well
so it turns out that in some settings it
might be okay to compromise on agreement
a little bit
uh but we'll talk about that later so
the property that paxos compromises on
is this one termination and that's what
you're usually going to choose so you
have a consensus algorithm
but it doesn't necessarily terminate
so i think with that we're probably
ready
to talk a little bit about paxos oh
great question in chat so the question
is if it doesn't terminate is agreement
satisfied
so agreement says all correct processes
decide on the same value
so if you don't
let's say let's say you got um one and
one and then this
process didn't produce a value here so
the what agreement says is that
if they produce a value then it's going
to be the same
ah there's a suggestion in chat about uh
sacrificing validity yeah
so the agreed upon value has to be one
of the proposed values
yeah i mean so it would be trivial to
say yeah we're always going to have
every process output foo
right and then regardless of whether foo
was what was proposed
um so but you could imagine other
kind of less horrible ways to um to give
up on validity right
like you could say well we'll attempt to
uh we'll we'll attempt to
pick one of the proposed values but then
maybe if some timeout expires
then uh then we'll we'll go with some
default value you could imagine
something like that
so that could be one way to to
compromise validity that could be
interesting
okay so let's talk a little bit about
paxos
so paxos is a consensus algorithm
that was invented by leslie lamport
he tried to publish it in 1990
but it took eight years for anybody
anybody to publish the paper
so it ended up first getting published
in 1998
and he used a kind of weird analogy in
this paper with
um this analogy to parliamentary
procedure with laws and voting and
things like that
and to this day some people use that
terminology to explain paxos
i prefer not to use that terminology
that's not my favorite
uh so i'm gonna avoid the stuff about
laws and voting and ballots and i'm
instead gonna stick mostly
to the terminology that he adopted later
on so he has another paper
from 2001 which he called paxos made
simple
which is the one that's much more often
read
and so i'm going to use the terminology
from this later paper
so paxos is really not just one
algorithm but it's a family of
algorithms meaning there are many
variants of it or flavors of it
and for now we're going to just talk
about boring vanilla
paxos and let me say also that
um in our discussion of you know what
consensus
means a second ago
so we were just talking about deciding
on one value
right so every process comes in
every process is allowed to have its say
and then
one value is getting decided on so
that's what we're going to be talking
about as well with paxis we're just
going to be just we're talking about the
problem of deciding on a single value
and later on we'll talk about uh how to
extend that to deciding on
a sequence of values so in paxos
there are three roles that a process can
play
and those roles are called proposer
acceptor and learner
so proposers propose values
acceptors
contribute to choosing from among the
proposed values
and learners
learn the agreed-upon value
so these are roles that a process can
play
in paxos now in practice a single
process could take on multiple roles
or even all of the roles so one process
could be all
of the roles
but when you're learning paxos it's
easiest to talk about the roles
separately so
we're going to be drawing pictures where
we have processes just playing a single
role
but in practice you could have one
process that's playing more than one
role
and we're going to call any node that
plays any role a paxos node
and node here is just a synonym for
process
so there are some things that have to be
kind of known in advance before the
algorithm runs
uh one thing is that paxos nodes have to
be able to persist data
so they have to be able to store data
and then
uh if they crash they have to be able to
get that data back that's so that they
don't forget what they accepted
so paxos nodes have to be able to
persist data
that's a little different from say the
key value store that you're implementing
for homework which is just an in-memory
key value store so it doesn't
persist data uh after a crash these are
we're assuming the ability to persist
data
there's another thing that has to be
true which is that paxos nodes have to
know
how many acceptors is a majority of
acceptors
so for instance if there's three
a majority is two if there's five
acceptors and majorities three
so all the nodes have to know how many
is a majority of acceptors so that
information is needs to be something
they have somehow
before the algorithm runs
all right so let's look at an actual run
of the algorithm
so for now for simplicity let's say that
there's
one proposer
and i'll call it p1
and let's say that there are three
acceptors
i'll call them a1 a2 and a3 and let's
say there's two learners
so every one of these is a process and
again keep in mind what i said a minute
ago about how
in practice you could have a particular
process
playing more than one role but for
learning the algorithm it's easiest if
we draw this picture
where each one of them is a separate
process
so here we've got three acceptors so the
majority of acceptors in this case is
going to be two
so let's say that our proposer p1 wants
to propose a value
the first thing that it does is it's
going to send a particular message
to a majority at least a majority of
acceptors
so the message that it's going to send
is called a prepare
message and it's going to pass something
along in that message
which is called the proposer the the
proposal number
so i'm going to call that n here so it
has to send what's called a preparer
message with some
n which is its proposal number and that
has to go to the
majority of acceptors so in this case
majority uh
is two it could also go to all three
just for simplicity let's just say that
it sends it to two let's just say that
it sends this to
a1 and a2
this proposal number has to be unique
nobody else can use it
so if you had multiple proposers you
would have to establish some rules in
advance
about who got to use which proposal
numbers so for example
maybe p1 could only use odd proposal
numbers
and p2 could only use even proposal
numbers if you had a p1 and a p2
so that's one thing that has to be true
so it's got to store the proposal
numbers that it's used and make sure not
to reuse them that's another reason why
nodes have to persist data
when an acceptor gets a prepare message
with a particular proposal number it's
going to look at that proposal number
and it's going to do a check it's going
to say did i
previously promise to ignore
requests with this proposal number
if the answer is yes it did previously
promise to ignore those then it ignores
it
so let's actually start to write down
some steps of this algorithm here
and i'll switch back and forth between
this picture and
a prose version of the steps
so we'll start with what happens on the
proposer's side
so the proposer is going to send
a prepare
message with a proposal number n
to at least a majority
and then n that's that's the proposal
number
and has to be unique
and it has to be higher
than any proposal number
that this particular proposer has used
before
so i'll label this here so you know what
it's called this is the proposal number
notice it's just higher than any
proposal number that this particular
proposer has used before it doesn't have
to be
higher than any that's been used
globally that would be very bad if that
were the case because
then you'd have to go check in with
everybody and say hey have you used any
proposal number that's higher than this
uh and if you haven't then don't because
now it's my turn and et cetera et cetera
so that would actually uh itself require
consensus
so that's no good so it's just higher
than any proposal number that this
particular proposer has used before
when those prepare messages get over to
the acceptor
on receiving
a prepare and message
the acceptor is going to look at that n
and it's going to do this check did i
previously promise
to ignore
requests
with this proposal number
so
it ignores it
if not
it now promises to ignore any request
with a proposal number lower than n
and it's going to reply
to the proposer
with a promise message
promise n and this means
i will ignore any request with a
proposal number lower than it
so the meaning of promise n is
i will ignore any request
with a proposal number lower than
that's what promise n means i'm going to
put a great big asterisk right here
because that's something that we're
going to have to come back to later when
we talk about the
hard parts okay so let's come back to
our picture here
let's actually put a real number here
instead of n
so let's say that uh our proposer p1
sends a prepare
five let's say that it sends it to these
two acceptors a1 and a2
and let's say that they both respond
with a promise five
okay let me take a look at chat here
yeah yeah great question so the question
about uh
if there are multiple proposers does n
have to be unique to everybody or does
it just have to be unique to this one
it has to it actually has to be globally
unique
uh and so that's why you have to have
the policy where like for instance if
you have two proposers then one of them
you have to decide in advance who gets
to use what so if you had two maybe you
would say one of them gets to use even
numbered proposal numbers and the other
one gets these odd numbered proposal
numbers
or if you had three then you could say
um you know one of them gets to only use
numbers that are
uh mod mod 3 or whatever
so and has to be unique
globally unique but that's something
that you can kind of decide in advance
by having these
disjoint sets of um
of proposal numbers that are available
uh to every one of the proposers
okay so
coming back to our run of paxos here
so p1 has sent its prepare message
prepare five to both a1 and a2
and they both responded with promise
five so we've now gotten a majority of
acceptors to promise
five keep in mind five is only the
proposal number it's not the actual
value we're deciding on
but still this is kind of an important
milestone right here
because now that we're at this point
where a majority have promised five
i'm going to call it milestone one now
that we're at this point
there can never be a majority that
promise four
or anything less than five why is that
the case well now that a majority have
promised five
if you tried to get a majority to
promise four
well that majority would have to include
one of these right
and they've both already promised five
and recall that promise
promise five means i'm going to ignore
any request with a proposal number lower
than five
so if somebody tried to come along at
this point and get everybody to promise
four
they wouldn't be able to or anything
else less than five
a minority might still promise for but
it would be impossible for a majority to
do so
so back to this outline here
so we can kind of label all this
as everything that i have on this page
as
paxos
phase one
up until milestone one this marker is no
good
so i didn't actually write it here but
this is the behavior of the pro
proposer and acceptor during this phase
and you get to the end of this phase
this phase ends when you've got when
that particular proposer has gotten a
majority of the acceptors to reply
with this promise end
okay but we're not done
there's going to be another phase so
we're back to the proposer
the proposer has collected
these promise messages for a particular
proposal number from a majority of
acceptors
when it does that we have the following
so at this point in phase two let's say
what
has happened at this point so
proposer has received
promise n
from a majority
of acceptors
for some n
for some particular n
at this point what the proposer will do
is it will send
what's called an accept message
and that accept message is going to have
two things and it's going to have the
proposal number
n and
it's going to have the value that you
actually want to propose
and this is going to be again at least
at least a majority of acceptors
so n
is the proposal number
that was promised up here
and val is the actual value it wants to
propose
i'm going to once again put a big
asterisk
because that's something else that we're
going to have to come back to
later on when we talk about the hard
parts
okay so back to our picture
so so far we haven't even talked about
the value we're proposing we've only
talked about the proposal number so now
we need to
actually propose a value um
so let's say what value should we
propose i don't know
let's say that the value that we're
proposing is foo
so proposer one is going to send out a
message
an accept message to a majority of
acceptors
just to keep it simple just have it be
the same two that we did before
so here five is the proposal number and
foo is the value that we're proposing
and by the way they don't have to be the
same two acceptors that we talked to
previously
they just have to be a majority but just
to keep this picture simple we'll do it
like that
now what well the acceptors get the
accept message
when the acceptors get the accept
message here's what happens
we'll come back to here
talking about paxos requires me to do a
lot of back and forth
so when the acceptor
gets one of these accept messages
it's going to ask itself
did i previously
promise to ignore requests
with this proposal number
if so
ignores it
should look familiar because we just
talked about that before in phase one
if not
it replies
with a new type of message
accepted
for that particular n in that particular
value
and also
sends that message
to all the learners
so now our picture would look like this
the accept message has gone out
the acceptors will ask did i previously
promise to ignore requests with this
proposal number
in this case they did not so they're
going to reply
with accepted
and they're also going to broadcast that
to the learners
the point when a majority of acceptors
send this accepted message so this point
right here
the point when a majority of acceptors
have sent
accepted messages for a particular
proposal number and value
that's the point when consensus can be
said to be reached
so this is another milestone
so from that point onward in the run of
paxos
we have consensus on foo not everybody
knows it yet at that point because this
is only the point at which
they've sent a majority of acceptors
have sent this message
so not everybody knows that we have
consensus even the acceptors themselves
don't know at that moment that we have
consensus
but we do so from that point onward
there's kind of no going back no matter
what happens from this point
so and at the point when
a proposer or a learner gets these
accepted
messages from a majority of acceptors
for a particular value and a particular
proposal number that
they know that consensus has been
reached
on that value so at this point right
here
at this point proposer one knows that
consensus has been reached on foo
so milestone two is when consensus
actually is reached
and then later there's sort of a third
milestone that happens independently
at the proposer and all of the learners
so right here
and right here and right here and that's
where each of these participants know
that consensus has been reached
so we'll come back to the part that i uh
wrote out earlier in case anybody still
needs to see it
let me go back and look at chat and see
if there's any questions left here
yeah great question so when we talk
about a majority of acceptors
right here for instance
this can be any majority of acceptors it
doesn't have to be the same majority
that we talked to before back in phase
one it could actually be any majority of
acceptors
in the picture that i drew we were
talking to the same majority of
acceptors in both phases i was talking
to a1 and a2
both times but it really just has to be
a majority any majority
and it's at least a majority right i
could send it to all of them
questions about this so i'll come back
here to the picture that we drew
so i'll write what i said before about
milestone three
so milestone three would be like right
here
and milestone 3 is when each of those
participants knows
that consensus has been reached
yeah okay another good question do the
acceptors have to send this
uh to all the learners or do they just
have to send it to a majority of
learners so we say that they send it to
all the learners
learners entire role in this algorithm
is to get sent
the the value on which consensus was
reached
now keep in mind that again roles a
particular process could play more than
one role
so maybe everybody is playing the
learner role
in which case they have to send that
message to everybody
but it learners this milestone three
like every learner is going to find out
individually at the point
when they've received this message that
says say accepted five foo for instance
from a majority
so everybody had better know what a
majority is everybody needs to know what
a majority of acceptors is
when that happens then they know that
consensus has been reached
so if you look back at phase one
here's what we wrote down for phase one
we left this big old asterisk right here
uh at the end of the behavior of the
acceptor
and it had to do with the reply here
and then for phase two we also have a
big old asterisk
right here that had to do with the
proposer so those are
places that there's something that we're
going to have to patch up because what
we actually do in those cases is going
to be a little bit more subtle
than i described but we're going to take
our break here
and so we've basically just done praxis
the easy parts
and we're going to come back and we're
going to patch up those asterisks
after the break so let me bring up our
quiz question
and it's 4 10 right now
so let's take a break until 4 20.
all right two minute warning
okay welcome back
okay so we just walked through
this example run of paxos
but we also left a couple of big
asterisks in our description of the
algorithm so
what we do in those cases is in fact a
bit more subtle than what we just talked
about
so we're going to go through the whole
thing again and this time we're going to
fill in those gaps
and with them filled in we're going to
be able to talk about
some more interesting runs of paxos
including runs that have more than one
proposer
okay so this is the example run of paxos
that we looked at
a minute ago we have one proposer three
acceptors so let's just review what
would happened here so the value we're
trying to decide on
uh or the value that p1 proposed here is
is foo
uh so we said there's three milestones
in this run the first milestone comes
when a majority
of acceptors have promised a particular
proposal number
in this case it was five
and that milestone i didn't really write
down what the meaning of that milestone
is so
the milestone is i'll just write it over
here
a majority of acceptors have promised a
particular proposal number
n so recall a promise of
n means i'm going to ignore any request
with a proposal number lower than n
and what this means this milestone is
that the acceptors will now
a majority of acceptors will never
accept a proposal numbered less than n
that's what you know when you've got
gotten to milestone what
we said milestone two is when consensus
is reached
and when that that happens when a
majority of acceptors have sent this
accepted
message for a particular proposal number
and a particular value
at that point consensus has been reached
even though nobody knows it yet so
that's kind of the point of no return
in this execution uh for for achieving
consensus on that value
and then the third milestone happens in
a sort of distributed if you will
fashion for every proposer or learner so
when a proposer or learner gets
this message from a majority an
an accepted message for a particular
uh n then they know
that consensus has been reached on the
value
so this is kind of like easy mode paxos
everything that i just showed you so
what we're going to do now
is go back and fill in the couple of
gaps that we had before
to understand why we have to do
something more to fill in the gaps
let's look at a case where there's more
than one proposer
so to make our diagram a little bit
simpler
i'm going to leave out the learners for
now so you could pretend they're still
there
we're just not going to put them in the
picture getting rid of them won't mess
anything up in this example
so we're going to say we're going to
have a proposer 1 and now we're also
going to have another proposer proposer
and we'll stick with our three acceptors
okay so
just like before let's say that p1 sends
out
its prepare message
with a proposal number five to a1 and a2
and let's say that these acceptors
respond with their promise
okay so first of all what would happen
if proposer 2
sent something like this
so let's say that it sent its prepare
for message to here
and
let's say that it also sent it to here
so what would happen then
so acceptor 2 is going to ignore right
because acceptor two already promised
five
that's right it's going to ignore so a2
is going to ignore this message for sure
now a3 didn't get didn't promise
anything previously so
a3 will respond
but recall what uh what proposers are
waiting for
right they're waiting to hear back from
a majority of acceptors
so p2 would never hear back from a
majority they would hear back from one
and so no they would be sitting here
forever
so p2 is over here keep in mind it has
no idea
you know what's going on with p1 right
p2
doesn't know that p1 is over here um
proposing things it just knows that it
sent a message and that it got no
response so what should it do
well it turns out that it's always okay
for a proposer to just go ahead and send
a higher numbered prepare message
so as long as the proposal number is
unique you're okay
so here i'm imagining that p1 has
claimed all of the odd numbered proposal
numbers and p2 has claimed all the even
numbered proposal numbers
but you could use any sort of scheme for
this as long as it ensures uniqueness
so p p2 is sitting here it didn't hear
back from a majority
you know maybe it gets one back from a
three if it happened to send to a3 but
it doesn't get the majority that it
needs in order to do anything
so in practice the way this would work
is that a proposer could have some sort
of a timeout
if it sends a prepare message to a
majority of acceptors and then it
doesn't hear back from a majority of
acceptors
then it can time out
and then it can send a higher numbered
one so let's say that after a while
p2's timeout expires and it decides to
send a new prepare message
well it hasn't used six yet and six is
the next even number so it can send a
prepare six
so let's say it sends that to here and
here
it could even send all three if it wants
to
so let's say this prepare six goes out
to all the acceptors
what do they do has any of them promised
to ignore requests with a proposal
number of six
no that's right they have not promised
to
ignore requests with the proposal number
six so they have to respond
but this is where that asterisk came in
so we've actually already hit
our second milestone in our
in this paxos run because what if this
was going on over here
what if while all this was happening
what if proposal
one had sent its accept messages here
and here
and let's say they responded with their
accepted messages so that's our
milestone two
right that we talked about before
but wait we just said that according to
the algorithm
none of these acceptors have promised to
ignore requests with a proposal number
of six so they have to respond
they have to respond to this prepare six
that came along
but consensus has already been reached
they just didn't know it yet
so what's what has to happen here
is that the acceptors are now
obligated to tell p2 that they already
accepted a value
so we have to do something a little bit
different than we did before
so we come back to this part where we
wrote this before
and we look at what the acceptor is
doing
so when we we said an acceptor when it
gets a prepare
prepare n message it asks did i
previously promise to ignore requests
with this proposal number if so it
ignores it
if no now it's going to have slightly
different behavior than it did before so
we're going to fix that first
asterisk and i'm going to put this on a
new page
this is our first asterisk cure
so the acceptor is now going to say
when it gets that prepare prepare and
message it's still going to say
did i previously promise
so you should already have this in your
notes from before this is the same
did i previously promise to ignore
requests with this proposal number
if so it ignores it
if not now this is the part that's new
it asks
have i previously
accepted
anything
so this is the part that's going to be
different
so i'll highlight it in red here
if yes
it's going to respond
with a promise message but it has to be
the proposal number of n that's the end
from up here
but instead of just um
just that it's going to pass along
something extra
and it's going to be a pair of
n prev alcal which is
its highest
previously accepted
proposal number
and then val prev
which is the previously accepted
proposal value
and then if not
it's going to reply with promise n
which is what it did before
so the stuff in the red box now is the
asterisk is the new stuff
so a promise message has this additional
component now
that only gets used in the case where
the acceptor has previously accepted
something
so let's see how this looks on our
picture
a1 and a2 get this prepared message of
6.
with this algorithm that we just added
this new asterisk to
what do a1 and a2 have to reply with
that's right yep they're going to reply
with a promise
of six but it's going to have this extra
thing
which is this pair of the previously
highest accepted proposal number and the
value
this one here is just going to respond
with a promise 6 because it didn't
previously accept anything
okay so now p2 has gotten promise
messages it's gotten promised responses
for everybody
for proposal number six that it sent out
but only one of them is
promise six like this and the other two
have this extra piece of information
tagging along which says
okay i promised six but alt
also by the way i previously
already accepted proposal number five
with the value foo
so we must have done that for a reason
right we said we must be sending that
information to p2 because
it has to do something with that
information
so that's going to bring us to our other
asterisk so let's look at what the
proposer is supposed to do
when it gets promise messages
so that's phase two
so phase two recall this is when a
proposer has received promise n
from a majority of acceptors for summit
so before
we said that when it's gotten that
promise n message from a majority of
acceptors it's going to send this accept
nval message where n is the proposal
number that was promised and val is the
actual value that it wants to propose
so i'm going to make a couple of small
corrections here
so how do you think that we're going to
have to tweak this part of the protocol
let me ask you
how do you think we're going to have to
change what the proposer does right here
it's gotten a promise message from all
of the acceptors
but some of them might have this extra
piece of information tagging along about
what was
previously accepted so the proposer is
going to have to use this information
somehow
what do you think it's going to have to
do
yeah good so the proposer is going to
have to take into account that extra
information that was included
so in particular it's going to have to
look at
[Applause]
these pairs that come along here
it's going to have to look at these
numbers
it's going to see whichever one is the
highest
and then the value that it has to
propose
is going to have to be the value that
went with that highest
previously accepted proposal number so
in particular to write it out in words
we're going to revise the protocol as
follows
so we're going to say when a proposer
has received promise messages and this
could be either kind
so i'll correct this right here so this
could be a promise of n
sorry there's a lot of parens there so
when it's received either kind of
promise message from a majority of
acceptors for some particular end
it's this part here that's going to have
to change
it's going to send the accept message
again to at least a majority of
acceptors where
n is the proposal number that was
promised so that's this end still
but this is the part that's going to
change
instead of just value being the actual
value that it wants to propose
we're going to say
val is chosen as follows
the proposer is going to have to ask
itself did it get any of these
pairs from any acceptors
if it did then the value that it's
proposing is going to be the
the one that went with the highest end
prev
so val is either
the val preve
that went with the highest
nprev
or if there are none of those then it
can do whatever it wants
so if it did get any of these pairs that
indicated that something had been
accepted previously
it has to propose the value that went
with the highest previously accepted
proposal number
if there aren't any of those it can
propose whatever it wants so
in our picture
we're on p2 so p2 can now send its
accept message out
it could send to every acceptor but it
only has to send to a majority so let's
let's say that it sends to a2 and a3
it's required to propose the value foo
because that's what it was told was
previously accepted
note that it's going to use its own
proposal number of 6
still so it's going to send its accept
messages out
so it's going to send six but it has to
propose foo because it's been told
that that was what was previously
accepted
so it didn't have to change its proposal
number to five or anything like that
it's sticking with six it just had to
make sure that the value it proposed
is the one that it's been told about
i actually find this very funny because
it's kind of like saying oh yeah you
wanted to participate sure you can
participate
so you can even use your own proposal
number if you want to you just have to
participate in exactly the way that we
tell you to
so this foo right here it didn't get to
make that decision on its own it had to
do what it was told
okay well what do the acceptors do now
well
what does an acceptor do when it gets an
except message what does the protocol
say
well it's gonna this let's look at a3 it
checks to see if it previously promised
to ignore requests with this proposal
number
in this case it did not so it's going to
reply with accepted
and then here again
and we can finish off our figure so
they're going to send this message of
accepted 6fu
back to the proposer and they're all
also going to send it out to the
learners i didn't have any learners on
this picture
note that this doesn't do anything to
invalidate this earlier consensus so
earlier we achieved consensus on foo
now we've also
told p2 that there's consensus on fu
right because
p2 is going to get these two messages
now for majority of acceptors saying
there's consensus on foo
it has a higher proposal number but the
value is the same
that's why we had to add that extra
little bit of subtlety in the behavior
of the proposers and acceptors it had to
do with this extra piece of information
that had to be passed along on promises
so
if an acceptor has already accepted
something
it has to say so in any future promise
messages
and that's to make sure that that
previously accepted value is going to
get repeated and reinforced
all right questions about this
right there's a couple of questions in
chat uh one person asks um
is there a way to to not have to pass
the value foo around
more than once so
you mean like um for example uh
like does it look like there's some
redundancy here where like a2 says
promise 65
foo and then we have to tell a2 what it
already knew right we had to tell it
what it already knew
by proposing foo and then having that
accepted yeah so that looks redundant
doesn't it
but look at a3 the first time that a3
found out about foo is right here
so a3 didn't know about any of this
other stuff
so a3 is only finding about foo for the
first time
uh right here so there does appear to be
some redundancy but that's because
there's some overlap in the
uh in in the majority sets
that we're dealing with here
uh another good question in chat why did
you need
because the only thing that's being used
here is foo why did you need this number
well you the reason you need that is
because
what the proposer is going to do when it
gets these messages back and when it has
to send its accepts
it's going to look at the the value here
that goes with the highest
numbered previously accepted proposal so
here they happen to be the same
so we didn't really exercise that code
path but what the proposer is going to
have to do and i'll put back this
this pros here so that you can see the
way that it's going to have to choose
what
value uh it can
it can it can propose
is by choosing the value that went with
the highest
uh previously accepted n
if there was one so in my picture
there were two uh that were the same
so so that didn't really come into play
but if they had been different then we
would need to pick the highest one we
would need to pick the value that went
with the highest one
okay there was another question in chat
another good question the question was
what if five has been promised but not
accepted yet when six is prepared
okay so what if this hadn't happened
over here
yeah then what would we have well then
if these promises had gone out but a1
and a2 had not yet accepted anything
then they would get these promise
messages
and what should a two's behavior be when
it gets a
when it gets a prepare message well
uh if you look back at what we wrote
down
actually let me let me do the patched
version instead of the um
uh the unpatched version here's the
patched version so when it gets a
prepare in
did i previously promise to ignore
requests with this proposal number
so it's going to ignore it if not then
it has to ask have i previously accepted
anything well
we're saying that didn't happen right
we're saying it didn't previously accept
anything because i just scribbled out
all of that acceptance there
so it's just going to be respond with
promise 6
in that case so then everybody's going
to come back here with promise 6
and at that point proposer 2 can send
accept 6 with anything it wants it can
propose bar
or whatever other value instead of foo
that it wants so
it would look a lot like this except
instead of having to propose foo
proposer 2 would get to propose any
value that it wanted
good questions all right
so we're almost done for today
and next time we're going to have to uh
wrap up our discussion of paxos so
uh just something to reflect on
uh between now and and next tuesday
think about what those three properties
were that we wanted uh
that we wanted a consensus algorithm to
satisfy so those were
uh termination
agreement
and validity
and i claim to you
that the one of these that paxos
compromises on because every consensus
algorithm has to compromise on one of
these
at least one of these under
under the asynchronous network model and
the crash fault model
i said that paxos compromises on
termination so it
might not terminate so now that we have
this full paxos algorithm up here in all
of its glory
um think about
what kind of a situation might lead to
paxos not terminating
and there was a great question in chat
just now like what if this happened
wouldn't proposer also get to propose
anything it wanted and i think you're
kind of on the right track here
about thinking about what might lead to
taxes not terminating
so we'll talk more next time about what
would happen in a run of texas that
didn't terminate
and how could you end up in such a
situation
and i don't think we have time to talk
about that today
at least i don't think i can do it in
three minutes so
excellent questions going on in chat
right now somebody just says
what if we just had one proposer
yeah if you just had one proposer
then things are easier in some sense
right you don't have to deal with this
sort of
interleaving proposer messages but also
if you only have one proposer
what do you do if it crashes
so that's no good so
having more than one proposer seems
pretty important because you wouldn't
want your sole proposal to crash
so we'll talk about that a little bit
more next time all right the last thing
that i want to leave you with today
is that the mid course survey is out
um i know some of you have already
filled it out already so if you did
thank you
and um it's due next tuesday at midnight
so it's only a couple of questions it
shouldn't take you more than a few
minutes to fill out and you get a little
bit of credit for it to help incentivize
you to do it so i really want to hear
from you
and hear how things are going so please
fill out the survey
tell me your thoughts and
i will do my best to read every single
survey response
and take them into account
all right thank you see you next week
you